vous pouvez pas faire autrement que vous
culpabilisez avec vous tous les jours
vous ne voyez pas passer ça
vous êtes né le 26 juillet 1952 à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine dans les
Yvelines fils d'ouvriers milieu modeste
où vous puissiez votre culte du travail
et l'envie de grimper les marches de
l'échelle sociale et aujourd'hui vous
êtes propriétaire d'un hôtel restaurant
à Chaumont-en-Vexin dans l'Oise
vous avez eu deux enfants d'un premier
mariage et un d'un deuxième Benjamin
dont le cas nous occupe ce soir alors
Benjamin très jeune est un enfant rieur
d'une intelligence au-dessus de la
moyenne si bien qu'il saute le CE2
tout à fait cette année d'avance qu'il
aille la gardera jusqu'au baccalauréat
tout à fait donc élève brillant mais
alors que tout parrain normal vous et
votre femme déceler chez Benjamin une
drôle de passion dès l'âge de 7 ans il
passe des heures au téléphone pour
participer à des jeux
radiophoniques et ils gagnent bon il a
quand même gagné téléviseur des
conséquences et on s'en a rendu compte
uniquement par les factures de téléphone
à l'époque on s'imaginait pas que
c'était de l'addiction si vous voulez on
la sermonner on s'est dit bon bah c'est
un gamin il joue alors son domaine de
prédilection c'est le foot il connaît
tous les joueurs leur parcours les
remplacer sur tout l'équipe de Marseille
voilà alors est-ce que vous ne
soupçonnez pas à l'époque en fait c'est
que cette passion est en train de
devenir une véritable obsession un jour
la famille est en vacances à Mimizan et
vous donner quelques euros à chaque
enfant pour s'acheter des bonbons des
sodas et quand Benjamin revient il a
gagné 30 euros l'équivalent de francs
avec un jeu à gratter oui on était
presque content de le voir
il a gagné quoi donc ses frères et
soeurs tu as de la chance Benjamin tu as
gagné etc quoi il a pas encore 10 ans à
l'époque oui il était jeune
alors là c'est le début de l'escalade
vers l'addiction la plus grande partie
de son argent de poche passe dans des
jeux à gratter on s'imaginait pas mettre
des barrières et que c'était une maladie
que c'était de l'addiction si vous
voulez alors Benjamin à 15 ans quand
vous êtes en Bretagne il fait un tour au
bureau de tabac il gagne 500 euros oui
resto pour toute la famille évidemment
tout le monde est content bien sûr non
et à 17 ans Benjamin décroche son bac S
donc avec un an d'avance il part dans
une école de commerce à La Rochelle et
là vous lui demandez de vous écrire
toutes les semaines ces dépenses quand
même je lui ai demandé de méfier un peu
quand même oui puis même pour l'habituer
si vous voulez lorsque vous laissez dans
la nature
un gamin parce que c'est un gamin à 17
ans
vous bon il est quand même à 500 ou 600
km du domicile donc on se dit bon il
faut quand même surveiller les dépenses
bon bah il le faisait pas trop en fait
et puis j'étais je reconnais un petit
peu laxiste à ce niveau là quoi un jour
vous tombez tous les deux sur un tournoi
de poker télévisé et là il commande la
partie vous dites je me suis rendu
compte qu'il était devenu très pointu
dans les combinaisons de poker bon c'est
vrai que ça ça attire l'attention quoi
ça
et puis un jour le 3 mars 2010 le jour
de ses 18 ans Benjamin se rend pour la
première fois de sa vie dans un casino
en quelques semaines il devient accro
vraiment au jeu et il a honte quand vous
découvrez qu'il a pas de quoi manger
correctement et que vous lui dites a été
au casino il baisse les yeux il est
comme tous les addicts au jeu s'il a
honte de lui en fait et quand vous
ouvrez le frigo qui ait rien dedans
enfin je veux dire on ressent qu'il y a
quelque chose quelque part et puis qu'il
pas de sous pratiquement pour terminer
le mois vous doutez bien que vous vous
demandez où c'est passé quoi je veux
dire alors là vous demandez à Benjamin
de rentrer à Chaumont mais vous
retrouvez dans sa chambre des cartes de
cercle de jeu quoi puis comment ça à
rentrer tard à découcher en fin des
choses qui sont des choses d'un addict
au jeu qui cachent un petit peu mais il
s'est fait
il accepte c'est de son plein de son
plein gré si vous voulez
on en parle après si vous voulez une
fois que ça a été découvert on en parle
là vous prenez une psychologue pour
l'aider à se soigner et il vous dit papa
je comprends pas j'ai des pulsions je
n'arrive pas à me contrôler c'est
touchant même oui c'est touchant parce
qu'il arrivait à parler
de lui-même il avait décidé d'aller voir
la psy bon précédemment de se faire
interdire de casino on avait fait venir
un une personne de Damien qui était venu
à la police de Beauvais pour nous faire
remplir les papiers qui il était tout à
fait d'accord il s'en rendait compte et
même il était gêné il était même honteux
si vous voulez
de son addiction oui parce que à part ça
tout va bien il fume pas non il fume pas
il boit le samedi soir avec ses copains
mais pas plus que ça les bosse
il est réceptionniste dans tel 4 étoiles
à côté de chez vous il vit avec sa peine
normalement en fait mais ça ne transpire
pas sur la partie addiction et sur la
partie jeu et voilà et malgré
l'interdiction de casino et la psy
Benjamin continue à jouer sur internet
parce que on peut se faire intérieur de
casino on va pas se faire interdire
d'Internet vous dites en fait il avait
deux vies et comment je m'en suis aperçu
parce que en fait il est face à
l'historique mais de temps en temps bah
il oubliait et puis après vous avez des
bannières si vous allez sur La Redoute
etc au bout de 15 jours vous avez 50
bannières à chaque fois que vous cliquez
quoi donc là c'est pareil je voyais des
bannières apparaître poker ceci poker
cela c'est bizarre moi je joue pas je
vais pas sur ces sites là il y a quand
même quelque chose j'ai déjà qui
continue quoi
et en avril 2012 Benjamin découvre les
jeux sur les paris sportifs américains
le basket Minnie très fort il gagne
entre 10 et 20 000 € à chaque fois quoi
oui tout à fait oui parce que en fait
comme il jouait 50 ou 100 fois le même
pari lorsqu'il gagnait il va gagner par
exemple 40 fois de 2047 euros et ça tous
les deux ou trois jours je m'imaginais
pas qui gagnait autant d'argent mais il
aurait dépensé c'était pas pour l'argent
de lui-même c'était pour l'adrénaline
pour le jeu
des fin mai 2012 il commence à perdre et
continue à jouer jusqu'au jour enfin
vous le saurez après sa mort il vous
vole un chèque de 16000 euros il m'a
pris un chèque sur mon chéquier il a
laissé en dépôt si vous voulez
chez un buraliste ça lui servait un
petit peu de caution c'est-à-dire que
même si il perdait il savait qu'il avait
un potentiel à jouer de 16000 euros dans
la journée ou tous les deux jours et
comme au bout de trois fois il regagnait
il payait donc ce chèque restait en
caution en permanence alors il emprunte
aussi de l'argent à un collègue de
travail il lui a demandé de lui laisser
un chèque en caution tout simplement
donc le copain lui a laissé un chèque
qui devait pas être encaissé c'était un
chèque de caution pour lui permettre de
rejouer une somme qui était
extraordinaire une somme de 53000 euros
et ce qui s'est passé le jour où il a
tout perdu qu'il a pas gagné il s'est
dit oh là là j'ai le chèque de caution
de mon père qui date du 2 avril c'est
16000 euros
j'ai le chèque du copain que j'ai fait
de 53000 euros qui m'a prêté qu'un
chèque de caution qui qui doit pas être
encaissé mais il va falloir que que je
rembourse aussi il a dû additionner tout
ça il a pas osé m'affronter il était
perdu il était perdu
le 24 mai dernier vers 10h30 vous
recevez un appel d'un ami de votre fils
qui n'arrive pas à le joindre quand vous
appelez vous tombez sur le répondeur
vous appelez votre campagne vous lui
demandez de le réveiller ce qu'elle fait
il se lève il quitte la maison vers
11h30 à 14h20 vous recevez un coup de
fil d'un collègue à lui qui me dit qu'il
est pas au travail et qui répond pas au
téléphone vous foncez chez vous vous
découvrez que son portable est sur
VIBREUR tout à fait
vous appelez la police les pompiers les
hôpitaux et à 20h30 vous apprenez qu'une
femme gendarme veut vous voir on a
retrouvé la voiture de Benjamin sur le
pont de Gennevilliers
une demi-heure après elle s'approche de
vous pour vous parler vous lui dites ça
va j'ai compris on va s'asseoir je sais
pas la peine madame c'est pas la peine
alors dans la voiture les gendarmes
retrouvent pour 17000 euros de tickets
de jeux perdants et une lettre oui papa
désolé mais j'en avais besoin ça va te
coûter un peu cher mais après il n'y
aura plus de dépenses bisous à toute la
famille en fait à la première lecture
vous pensez qu'il parle du prix des
obsèques et bah exactement parce que je
ne m'imaginais pas qu'il pouvait avoir
fait en une journée un tel trou si vous
voulez et avoir joué une telle somme
d'argent je pensais pas au jeu ni à
l'addiction
enfin c'est mettez-vous à la place d'un
père qui découvre un relevé de compte
qui découvre et donc je l'ai appris
après parce qu'à la première lecture de
la lettre effectivement je me dis bah
tiens ça va te coûter un peu cher parce
que moi je pensais enfin je suis désolé
mais je pouvais pas passer à autre chose
quoi je veux dire et en fait vous
découvrez les sommes astronomiques des
fois c'est le mois précédent vous
comprenez les raisons du suicide de
votre fils vous culpabilisez aujourd'hui
alors c'est ambigu j'ai dit à tout le
monde non je culpabilise pas parce que
tout le monde me dit il faut pas que
j'ai pas baisé mais vous rendez bien
compte que je peux pas faire autrement
vous pouvez pas faire autrement que vous
culpabilisez avec vous tous les jours
vous ne voyez pas passer ça comment
comment vous voulez faire vous vous
dites mais c'est pas possible vous
saviez qui je savais qu'il jouait il
était suivi mais pas descendre pareil
pas descendre pareil
mais on est tombé de haut je veux dire
on s'imagine pas
comprends pas voilà je pense que aussi
la société à sa part de responsabilité
dans voilà l'état évidemment parce qu'il
y a de l'argent évidemment mais est-ce
que il y a une responsabilité collective
là qui est pas une responsabilité
simplement des parents parce que c'est
difficile pour les parents de lutter
contre l'écran de télé et qu'entre ces
héros qui sont fabriqués par les écrans
de télé tu as raison il y a pas de loi
et 20 pour les jeux alors qu'il y en a
pour l'alcool surtout pour les enfants
majeurs c'est en fait c'est ce sont
quand même aussi des enfants majeurs
vous pouvez pas non plus tout interdire
voilà merci de votre témoignage et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu